[Musique]
la french tech Paris Saclay rassemble
une communauté de start-up on est plus
de 500 startups qui ont un lien avec le
territoire de Paris sacré et nous
rassemblons maintenant presque 300
adhérents startup à la french Chuck
Paris sacrée alors notre vocation
qu'est-ce qu'on propose à ces startups
c'est bien entendu de les faire
rencontrer entre elles pour qu'elle
puisse partager leur retour d'expérience
et puis bien entendu les mettre en
relation avec tout type d'acteurs qui
peuvent les aider tant sur le plan
administratif que sur le plan
technologique le territoire de Paris
Saclay est un écosystème d'innovation
très riche en effet grâce en plus de 600
startups plus de 65000 étudiants et plus
de 40 lieux d'innovation alors qu'est-ce
que sont les lieux d'innovation ce sont
toutes les structures qui accompagnent
les startups tout au long de leur
développement la french tech Paris
Saclay est constituée de deux personnes
à temps plein qui
œuvrent tous les jours pour aider ces
startups dans ces mises en relation pour
cela nous proposons aussi plusieurs
programmes qui leur permet d'être aidé
tant sur le plan de financement ou sur
le plan d'accès à des locaux
particuliers sur le territoire et qui
sont bien entendu adaptés à leur
activité la principale a la chance
d'avoir plusieurs partenaires publics
privés nous concentrons par exemple les
collectivités telles que les communautés
d'agglomération de Paris Saclay 50 ans
en Yvelines et vers sa grand parc nous
concentrons également d'autres
partenaires privés tels que des banques
des cabinets de conseils qui nous aident
tous les jours ou quasi tous les jours
en tout cas à proposer des services
adaptés pour ces startups du territoire
au jour le jour la french tech Paris
Saclay aide les startups à être mises en
relation avec des services publics pour
se faire nous avons lancé un programme
qui s'appelle French tech central qui
permet d'accueillir des intervenants des
institutions publiques dans nos locaux
au plaid round à Palaiseau et les
startups peuvent prendre rendez-vous au
travers de notre plateforme qui
s'appelle la french tech centrale de
Paris-Saclay pour permettre de prendre
rendez-vous directement avec ses
intervenants
ce programme French tech central permet
ainsi aux startup d'avoir des réponses
très rapidement à leurs questions sur le
plan administratif grâce au rendez-vous
qu'on propose dans ce bâtiment le
plérande de Palaiseau la Fring chaque
Paris Saclay co organisée organise des
événements ouverts au public dans lequel
vous aurez la possibilité de rencontrer
des startups je vous invite d'ailleurs à
rejoindre l'événement du 1er juin qui
s'appelle spring et qui aura lieu HEC en
jouet en Josas
[Musique]